wie schön dass Sie dabei sind an diesem
historischen Freitag Olaf Scholz der
wichtigste Lieder der freien Welt
besucht genau heute den zweitwichtigsten
also Joe Biden in Washington und das in
der Zeiten wenden Jubiläumswoche vor
genau einem Jahr das wissen sie wurde
die zeitenwände ausgerufen ja eine echte
Zäsur
inzwischen hat sich allerdings
herausgestellt einfach nur ganz oft
zeitenwände sagen reicht wohl gar nicht
komisch aber der Digitalisierung und
beim Klimaschutz hat es doch genauso
geklappt
wieder hat's auch nicht geklappt
ach so kein Wunder das Scholz gestern im
Bundestag einen Lacher geerntet hat der
wohl gar nicht vorgesehen war auch
Deutschland ist im Lichte der
Zeitenwende widerstandsfähiger geworden
am deutlichsten wird das wenn man auf
die Bundeswehr blickt wir machen Schluss
wir machen muss Schluss
ja du weißt irgendwas läuft furchtbar
schief wenn bei einer Rede von Olaf
Scholz gelacht wird
der Chef vom Bundeswehrverband sagt bei
ihnen habe sich im letzten Jahr Zitat
nichts spürbar verbessert Alter nichts
das ist hart ja man sei weder voll
einsatzfähig noch abwehrbereit
wir haben den doch 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen spendiert aber da gibt es
ja jetzt die 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen wie viel ist davon denn
schon bei der Truppe angekommen
ziemlich genau gar nichts
dazu fällt ein ziemlich genau gar nichts
mehr ein Freunde
2022 sind 0 Euro abgeschlossen im
laufenden Jahr etwas mehr als ein halbes
Prozent vom Sondervermögen was wohl auch
mit ja komplizierten Bestellvorgängen zu
tun hat habe ich gelesen in der neuen
Zeiten werden die ja
habe ich abonniert
ein ganzes Jahr verschenkt verschenkt
dabei haben Experten von Anfang an
gewarnt erst die Beschaffung reformieren
dann frisches Geld nicht umgekehrt und
zügiger produzieren wer vielleicht auch
eine Idee aktuell sind wir mehr oder
weniger in manufakturbetrieb drei
kampfanze Leopard pro Monat wenn wir das
europäisch abstimmen gehe ich davon aus
dass sie drei 400 in den nächsten zwei
bis 400 Jahren brauchen
[Applaus]
ja in 400 Jahren das ist zu schaffen
ich sag mal dann ist Putin
wahrscheinlich immer noch Präsident
ein Sondervermögen gammelt hier
ungenutzt vor sich hin dann hätte man
das Geld auch sinnvoller nutzen können
Beispiel ich gebe mal ein Beispiel wenn
ich 100 Milliarden Euro in 1 Cent Münzen
Wechsel ergibt das 10 Billionen Münzen
dann haben unsere Soldaten zwar immer
noch keine Munition aber sie können die
Cent Stücke super mit einer Zwillinge
flutschen
oder wir wechseln das Geld in 100 €
Scheine und nehmen den Soldaten daraus
neue Tarnkleidung alles besser als die
Kohle einfach liegen lassen ne alles
besser na gut jetzt ist die Bundeswehr
natürlich nur eine Seite der zeitwände
Medaille da sind ja schließlich auch
noch unsere Brett hatten Russland
Sanktionen tja die EU hat gerade erst
das zehnte Sanktionspaket beschlossen
nimm das Putin jetzt ist Russlands
Wirtschaft nach iwf-schätzungen in
diesem Jahr mit 0,3% am Wachsen und
damit stärker als die deutsche
Konjunktur
ja weil wir den Handel mit Drittstaaten
nicht unterbinden können und weil unsere
Sanktionen immer noch zu soft sind sie
sind zu soft meine Damen und Herren auch
beim zehnten Paket konnte sich die EU
wieder nicht darauf einigen keine
russischen AKW Brennstäbe mehr zu kaufen
kaufen will immer noch Europa importiert
weiter Flüssiggas aus Russland warum
selbst der Diamantenhandel wird immer
noch nicht sanktioniert weil sich da
Belgien quer stellt mit Belgien
ja allein die Stadt Antwerpen spült
Putin so pro Jahr über eine Milliarde in
die Kriegskasse nur Antwerpen dafür gibt
es jetzt und es ist leider kein Witz ein
Exportverbot für europäische Toiletten
und bides
gerade zu filmreif
von den Machern des Kinohits
Sanktionspaket 1 Sanktionspaket 2 und
Sanktionspaket 3 bis 9 kommt jetzt etwas
völlig neues
sanktions Paket 10
der erste Actionkracher komplett ohne
Action endlose Sitzungen in denen
EU-Staatschefs zum zehnten Mal sagen man
müsste echt mal russische brandstäbe
sanktionieren um dann auf eine viel
härtere Strafe zu kommen ein
Exportverbot von
scheißhäusern
diese Sanktionen kannst du durchs Klo
spülen und Moskau ist wichtigster
Filmkritiker sagt
ich habe sehr gelacht sehen Sie Jürgen
Drews als ursula von der Leine Veronika
Faris als ein turniertes Dixi Klo und
wie immer Armin Laschet als Boris
Pistorius sanktions Paket 10 jetzt wird
zurückgeschossen
[Applaus]
ja
könnte mir sehr gut vorstellen der Putin
guckt gerade viel deutsches Fernsehen
letzten Samstag zum Beispiel Phönix live
von der großen Friedensdemo in Berlin
tausende Menschen am Brandenburger Tor
singen zusammen mit Alice Schwarzer und
Sarah Wagenknecht imagine
magine von John Lennon die legendäre
Ukraine gibt endlich auf Hymne
friedenshymne
friedenshymne mein Fehler entschuldigung
mein Fehler im Publikum vor der Bühne
bei dieser Demo sah man viele russische
und fast keine ukrainische Fahne was
sehr lustig ist weil in Moskau hätten
sie so eine Demo natürlich direkt
aufgelöst inklusive massenhaftung und
das unterstreicht wunderbar welche Werte
die Ukraine verteidigt ansonsten ist uns
aufgefallen wurde Frau Wagenknecht von
den Fans frenetisch gefeiert in Berlin
die Frau Schwarzer ihr nicht so hier
nicht so aber gut das ist natürlich auch
ja
das ist jetzt ein unfairer Vergleich ich
meine die eine ist gelernte demologen
und die andere eine 80-jährige
Feministin mit Technik problems
darum heißt der abnutzungskrieg stimmt
was mit dem Metron nicht noch mehr
ja stehen wir hier jetzt ah danke Sarah
ah ja ja Zufall Zufall aber Mikro
richtig rum halten ist übrigens auch das
Thema in der neuen Ausgabe der Emma die
heißt gar nicht mehr so na das wusste
ich nicht
[Musik]
über 700.000 Menschen haben ihr Manifest
unterschrieben obwohl darin der Satz
fehlt Putin muss sich aus der Ukraine
zurückziehen dafür steht aber drin Zitat
es ist Zeit uns zuzuhören also nicht den
Ukrainern die um ihr Überleben kämpfen
sondern uns den besorgten deutschen weil
sie wie es Ihnen geht aber etwas mehr
Empathie mit den überfallenen wäre schon
schön oder ich finde es gut Sarah
Wagenknecht fordert Waffenlieferungen
stoppen und sofort mit Putin reden
endlich verhandelt ergebnisoffen also
solange klar ist das Russland in jedem
Fall mehrere fette Scheiben Ukraine
behalten darf ist ja logisch also ich
verstehe von ukra inischer Warte aus
dass man natürlich sich sehnlich wünscht
dass die Russen einfach abziehen und da
wäre der Krieg zu Ende
realistisch es wird nicht so sein ja
alles Land zurück kriegen ist
unrealistisch ist total unrealistisch
nach der Logik steht uns rückwirkend
noch halb Frankreich zu aber das nur am
Rande wir wollen es ja gar nicht
sondern mit Frankreich
60 Prozent der Deutschen oder rund 60
Prozent der Deutschen haben in einer
Umfrage gesagt sie wären für mehr
diplomatische Bemühungen ja klar ich
meine wer ist denn gegenverhandlung ich
behaupte wir sind gar nicht gespalten in
Kriegstreiber und friedensporter okay
was stimmt man versucht uns zu spalten
der russische Propaganda versucht
ständig die europäische Gesellschaft zu
spalten die lieblingspolitikerin auf die
sich das Regime in Europa verlassen kann
ist dabei tatsächlich Sarah Wagenknecht
Wagenknecht beliebteste deutsche in
Putins Russland
die nächste Demütigung für Gerd Schröder
wirklich gespalten sind gerade die
Linken Teile der Partei werfen nämlich
Sarah Wagenknecht vor sich nicht genug
nach rechts abzugrenzen und wir schalten
mal live nach Berlin vor das Karl
Liebknecht Haus zu Mandy hausten von der
Linkspartei Mandy verschärft Wagenknecht
die Krise der Linken
sie ein kurzes
[Gelächter]
linke Politik wird gebraucht und zwar
mehr denn je ja meine Regierung die Geld
für Panzer hat aber nicht für Kinder
Grundsicherung ich selbst bin
alleinerziehende Mutter des kleinen Mike
mit AI und der Vater zahlt nicht
wenn du das hörst dir sollte man den
piepan mit der rostigen kneifen danke
okay ich formuliere die Frage an wenn
sich die Linke spaltet auf welcher Seite
stehen sie dann
doch nichts vor Oliver
ist doch das einzige bekannte Gesicht
dass wir noch haben unsere Vorsitzenden
heißen wusste ich googeln
Janine Wissler und Martin Schirmer waren
wer zum Anhänger ist Martin schulzahn
kennt keiner die Mutter von Martin schon
weiß nicht wer Martin schon ist
[Musik]
ich sage wenn Sarah Wagenknecht geht
können wir die alle miefburger hier
dicht machen
Punkt
und dann machen sie mit in der neuen
wagenknecht-partei Quatsch nein
verteilen sie total
aus bitte hat man eine sogenannte
Bewegung
IVer gemacht
[Musik]
und so besieht mit schon geh zu ihm
Mädchen und guck mal wie süß der Oskar
sich hier freut weil die Sarah immer
erlaubt hat mal länger aufzubleiben
aber nur ausnahmsweise
das waren schlimme Bilder und was ist
das Programm eurer Bewegung
er braucht schon Programme wenn er eine
sarah hat die hat doch sowas wie Inhalte
längst überwunden und Oliver sie haben
doch bloß Angst vor starken Frauen
dann lässt er sich ein der kleine das
ist
Wagenknecht ist nicht AG 2018 mit
Hashtag aufstehen was aber Hashtag keine
Sau interessiert hat dann agitiert sie
gegen angebliche sprechverbote
Arbeitsmigration und jetzt eben gegen
Waffen für die Ukraine Hauptsache
Talkshow Einladung
Assistent
unsere Bewegung hat eine ganz klare
inhaltliche Agenda wir nennen uns die
sozialistische Alternative Rosso viele
Amerika
kurz Sarah
so wo ist das denn mit der Person
ihr macht den konkurrenzladen direkt
nebenan auf ja na und wir waren die
Mieten günstig nehmen da links verteilen
will nämlich gerade keiner mehr wollen
ja aktuelle Phase Umfrage
19% der Deutschen könnten sich
vorstellen eine Wagenknecht verteilt zu
wählen nein sie Prozent Oliver das sind
das sind ungerechnet 4 fdps
ja und deswegen legen wir direkt los mit
coolen messages für die tiktok Hits von
heute hier
betonfrisur und selbstgerecht das ist
unsere Wagenknecht so feiern wir den
späten Sieg des Sozialismus immer bereit
Freundschaft von mir aus Mandy
die haben gesagt die soll man den
Lieblingswitz erzählen was mache ich
gerne also kommen ein Pferd Jeff Bezos
und der Papst in eine Bar sagt der
Barkeeper abonniert endlich den
verkackten heute schon Kanal also geht
doch